يزور رئيس الوزراء العراقي طهران لبحث
ملفات منها الثنائي كمستقبل العلاقه
بينهما خاصه مع الازمه الداخليه في العراق
ومنها ما هو اقليمي كالوضع السوري
والعلاقه بين ايران ودول
الخليج
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين ما هي اهداف ايران والمالك من هذه
الزياره وتاثيرها على مستقبل العلاقات
بينهما وما هي النتائج المتوقعه من
المباحثات اقليميا خاصه وان العراق هو
الرئيس الحالي للقمه
العربيه السلام عليكم
ملفات متشابكه يذهب بها نوري المالكي الى
ايران داخليا يواجه رئيس الوزراء العراقي
ازمه سياسيه اقليميا انتهى للتو من حرب
تصريحات مع نظيره التركي عربيا تشتعل
الثوره السوريه في الجاره الغربيه بينما
اكبر داعم لنظام بشار الاسد هو ايران
جارته الشرقيه كما ان الازمه الدبلوماسيه
الخليجيه الايرانيه بسبب جزر الخليج
الامارات الثلاث لم تخف حدتها والعراق هو
رئيس القمه العربيه لكن ذلك لم نمنع لم
يمنع عفوا المالكي من زياره طهران قبل اي
عاصمه عربيه
اخرى قراءه اسماء وزراء التجاره والتخطيط
والصناعه والمعادن بين مرافق رئيس الوزراء
العراقي الى ايران قد تعشر مبدئيا الا ان
هدف الزياره مجرد محادثات بين بلدين جارين
بينهما من للفات شائكه ليس اقلها حقول
النفط المشتركه الا ان سياقات الزياره
الاقليميه والدوليه تعطيها ابعادا يختلط
فيها الداخلي بالثنائي والاقليمي عشيه
الزياره تطيرت تصريحات اللاذعه بين نور
المالك ونظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اتهم المالكي بالانانيه واثاره توترات بين
السنه والشيعه والاكراد ورد المالك بوصف
تركيا بانها دوله معاديه ياتي هذا على
خلفيه محادثات اجراها اردوغان مع مسعود
البرزاني رئيس اقليم كردستان العراق ومع
نائب الرئيس العراقي طارق الهاشمي الذي
غادر بغداد بعد اتهامه بالتورط في عمليات
ارهابيه وترافقت هذه المحادثات مع تلويح
في الداخل العراقي باعاده ترتيب التحالفات
البرلمانيه بصوره قد تطيح بالمالك من
رئاسه الحكومه وهنا تبرز اهميه الحفاظ على
تماسك احزاب التحالف الوطني الداعم للمالك
وللمرجلة
مشاركه امير دوله الكويت كان تمثيل بقيه
دول الخليج العربيه ضعيفا وقد اعتبر هذا
رساله للحكومه العراقيه واشير الى تجاوزها
بعض الفئات كسنه واكدت الرساله الخليجيه
مجددا اختلاط اوراق الداخل العراقي
بالمتغيرات الاقليميه
المتسارعه اخر المتغيرات انتقاد دول
الخليج العربيه الحاد لزياره الرئيس
الايراني لجزيره ابو موسى في الخليج وهي
احدى ثلاث جزر تعتبر ها الامارات ارضا لها
وتتهم ايران باحتلالها فيما بدا تعزيزا
لحاله الاستقطاب وتعقيدا لمحاوله الاجابه
عن الكيفيه التي يصوغ بها البلد الذي
يتراس القمه العربيه مواقفه
الاقليميه معنا في هذه الحلقه من طهران
الدكتور حسن علي الدبلوماسي الايراني
السابق واستاذ القانون الدولي من بغداد
واثق الهاشمي رئيس المجموعه العراقيه
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن دبي الدكتور
عبد الخالق عبد الله استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الامارات اهلا بضيوفنا
الثلاثه لو بدانا من طهران الكتور حسن علي
ما ابرز ما تريده طهران من زياره السيد
نوري
المالكي يبدو ان طهران لم يسمع السؤال اذا
نوجه نفس السؤال ولكن للضفه الاخرى نسال
السيد واثق الهاشمي عن ابرز ما يمكن ان
يكون نوري المالكي يبحث عنه في
طهران نعم شكرا جزيلا يعني السيد المالكي
لديه ملفات عده في هذه الزياره منها ما هو
ثنائي في العلاقات بين الطرفين ولكن هناك
ملفات اخرى مهمه على الصعيد اللوجستي وعلى
الصعيد التغيرات الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
والتهديدات الكبيره جدا هناك مشاكل عالقه
بين البلدين فيما يخص قضيه الطاقه
والكهرباء والمياه الحقول المشتركه هناك
مشكله ان الجانب الايراني بدا بتصدير وسحب
كثير
من كميات النفط عبر الحقول المشتركه وهذا
مولد ازعاج الى كثير من النواب في
البرلمان العراقي قضايا اخرى ايضا مشتركه
بين الطرفين لكن انا اعتقد القضيه الاهم
والعاتق والمشكله الاهم على السيد المالكي
انه يمثل القمه العربيه او رئيسا للدوره
الحاليه للجامعه العربيه بالتالي ما يحدث
ما حدث من ايران من من زياره السيد نجاد
الى جزيره ابو ابي موسى ولد مشكله كبيره
في المنطقه كيف سيجاب السييد المالكي هذه
القضيه و كيف سيطرح هذه الامور مع الجانب
الايراني الذي لديه مشاكل ايضا متعدده
بتوجيه ضربه امريكيه واسرائيليه مع وجود
مشاكل اخرى مع دول متعدده في المنطقه اذا
الزياره شائكه وصعبه وفيها الكثير من
الملفات التي ستطرح وقد يكون الملف السوري
من اهم الملفات الموجوده ل وجود اختلافات
حتى في وجهات النظر بين الدول العربيه
وتركيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
قضيه سوريا وهناك الجانب الايراني الذي
يقف مع النظام في سوريا بالطبع الاشاره
الى موضوع الجزر الثلاث وهنا نسال الدكتور
عبد الخالق عبد الله هل لدى ابو ظبي اي
شعور بان نوري المالكي سيطرح فعلا هذه
القضيه في
طهران يعني واضح اولا ان توقيت الزياره
ياتي في في سياق تطورات كثيره في المنطقه
وان الزياره تاتي في وقت تظهر ايران كل
هذا الاستعلاء وتقوم بمثل هذه الزيارات
الاستفزازيه والعدائين ولا تتقيد بحسن
الجوار خاصه في زياره احمدي نجاد الاخيره
لابو موسى واعتقد الزياره توقيتها ايضا ان
هذه اول زياره الان يقوم بها المالكي الى
خارج العراق بعد القمه العرب
ويذهب مباشره الى طهران فايضا التوقيت
مثير لحفيظه و زياره مالكي الان
ل لطهران تزيد من شكوك من الشكوك العربيه
والشكوك الخليجيه بانه هو رجل ايران القوي
في بغداد نتمنى الان بعد ان استلم العراق
رئاسه القمه ان هو يمثل العراقي اولا
ويمثل العرب ثانيا و يطرح كافه القضايا
العربيه لساه في طهران وفي مقدمه هذه
القضايا الاستفزاز الاخير والزياره
العدائيه التي قام بها احمدي نجاد سيد
الهاشمي ونحن بالطبع في انتظار نتمكن من
الاتصال بالسيد حسن علي في طهران سيد
الهاشمي اشرت الى الموضوع
السوري الموضوع السوري تقريبا هناك شبه
اتفاق تقريبا بين بغداد وبين طهران في
المقاربه السوريه هل تعتقد بان سيكون
السيد نوري المالكي قادر على اضافه شيء
لهذا الملف عندما يذهب الى
طهران يعني دعني في البدايه اوضح وجهه نظر
مهمه في قضيه سوريا الجانب العراقي وعلى
صعيد اكثر من صعيد رسمي وداخل الكتل
السياسيه وحتى على صعيد الحكومه العراقيه
الرسميه انها ليست مع النظام في سوريا هم
مع شعب سوريا في تقرير مصيره وهذه وجهه
النظر نقلها العراق في اكثر من مكان
وحضراتكم تتذكرون جيدا ان العراق قدم دعوه
شكوى رسميه في مجلس الامن ضد النظام في
سوريا رغم العلاقات الجيده بين العراق
وايران وكانت هناك ضغوط ايرانيه لثني
العراق عن هذا الموضوع العراق ي سيد هاشمي
هذا كان هذا كان قبل اشهر عن قبل ان تتحسن
العلاقات العراقيه السوريه ويصبح هناك ما
يشبه المثلث في راي بعض المحللين طهران
دمشق بغداد
انا اتكلم عن الموقف الرسمي الان العراق
يقول انا مع شعب سوريا في تقرير مصيره لكن
لا تكون عن طريق اراق الدماء ونزيف الدم
سيؤثر على كل المنطقه وهذه وجهه النظر
تختلف عن الجانب الايراني التي يدعم
النظام بسوريا وبقوه في شتى الاتجاهات
العراق كان يرغب بمبادره تشبه المبادره
الخليجيه في قضيه اليمن بان يكون هناك
تبادل سلمي للسلطه بوجود نائب الرئيس
السوري وتشكيل حكومه مؤقته وبالتالي
انتخابات الدستور هكذا هي وجهه النظر
العراقيه الرسميه على الاقل قد تكون
مختلفه مع ايران في قضيه الدعم الكامل الى
نظام بشار الاسد لكن هذه القضيه ولدت
مشاكل مع جاره تركيا مع بعض دول الخليج
والان قد يذهب المالكي الى ايران لطرح
وجهه نظر في هذا الموضوع حول القضيه
السوريه لكن هل هل
هو قادر وهنا اسال الدكتور عبد الخالق عبد
الله هل هو قادر ربما على ايصال وجهه
النظر العربيه الى تهران في يتعلق بالجزر
وقد يكون قادر على لعب دور معين مع طهران
بحكم هذه العلاقه الحميمه بين
الطرفين يعني نامل ذلك ونتمنى ان العراق
بعد ان استلم رئاسه الدوره الحاليه
للجامعه العربيه ان يتحمل مسؤوليته
بالكامل لكن يعني المالكي معروف انه شخصيه
جدليه وشخصيه خلافيه في داخل العراق وخارج
العراق ولا يمكن الرهان عليه واعتقد من
المهم ان نفصل بين المالكي من ناحيه
واجندات السياسيه الشخصيه من ناحيه وبين
العراق ومواقفه العروبيه وانتمائه العربي
ورغبته في القيام بدوره العروبي وتوثيق
صلته بمحيطه العربي يعني اعتقد الرهان على
مالكي صعب جدا واعتقد من المهم جدا لنا
كعرب اننا نفرق ان ان المالكي لا يمثل
حاليا كل الطيف العراقي كما ذكر الدكتور
واثق واعتقد ان العراق اجندته عربيه
والتزم بذلك وعليه ان يحافظ على الاجماع
العربي خلال هذه الفتره لكن مع الاسف
الشديد يعني المالكي لا يمكن الرهان عليه
ولديه اجنده قريبه جدا من الاجنده
الايرانيه في في العراق الاجنده الايرانيه
في العراق اساسها ابقاء العراق على شيعيه
العراق وعلى الوجه الطائفي للعراق وميول
مالكي قريبه جدا من ميول ايران في هذا
البند لكن لا اعتقد اننا ينبغي ان ندفع
بالمالكي وحتما لا ينبغي ان ندفع بالعراق
في احضان في احضان ايران هذا ما تتمناه
ايران وينبغي ان نكون حاضرين في ذلك
وينبغي علينا ايضا كما ذكرت فصل بين
المالكي واجنه من ناحيه وبين العراق
ومسؤوليته العروبيه حاليا ورغبته وحرصه
على تقويه علاقاته في بمحيطه العربي خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالقضيه السوريه ربما هناك
توافق مالكي ايراني اجاه الملف
السوري لكن ليس بالضروره توافق عراقي
ايراني فموقف العراق واضح واثير هنا بشكل
خاص ان مثلا شخصيه مثل هشار زيباري
المفروض يكون مع وزير رئيس الوزراء
الماركي وهو غائب عن الوفد العراقي ربما
لهذا ايضا بعض الدلالات نعم تمكنا الان من
الاتصال بطهران الدكتور حسن علي قمنا
بجوله بين ضيفين في العراق وضيفنا في دبي
وكان هناك تقريبا تاكيد على الطابع
الثنائي لهذه الزياره ولكن ايضا ملف سوريا
وملف الجزر
ربما سيحظي باهميه بالنسبه
لطهران ما الذي تريده تحديدا من زياره
المالك
برايك بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم كما تعلمون
ان العراق تتراس القمه العربيه ولديها حسن
العلاقات مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه
وان هذه الزياره في هذه الظروف وخاصه بعد
التوافق الذي حصل في اسطنبول والتاكيد على
ادامه المفاوضات في بغداد هذا يعني بان
الدبلوماسيه العراقيه نجحت وتتمكن ان تخدم
المصلحه الايرانيه والعراقيه في المجالات
المختلفه السياسيه ومنها حل الازمه
النوويه واتصور ان ملفات سوريا والبحرين و
ايضا الملفات الاخرى التي لابد ان ندرسها
مع الجانب العراقي لان الجانب العراقي
لديه امكانيه جيده لتحسين
ظروف الناس في البحرين وايضا في سوريا
وبقيه الدول التي تواجه هذه الازمات
وايران ايضا تلاحظ بصوره
جيده تنميه العلاقات الاقتصاديه والثنائيه
بين دوله الرئيس المالكي و والسيد رحيمي
كرئيس وزراء للعراق ونائب رئيس الجمهوريه
في في ايران الاسلام وكل هذا يعني بان
ايران تدارك ان تتمكن ان تلعب دورا جيدا
في نجاح الامور داخل العراق وايضا نجاح
كافه الامور التي تتابعها في الازمه
النوويه الايرانيه وتحسين ظروف التفاوض مع
الجانب العراقي وايضا الجانب الاوروبي في
هذا المجال كما تعلمون اول تفاوض امريكي
عراقي كان عراقي ايراني كان في بغداد
واليوم نرى ان بعد شهر من من هذه المده
سوف يكون التفاوض مع الجانب العراقي
والايراني والاوروبي في بغداد وهذا يعني
بان عرا العراق تلعب دورا بالوساطه في حل
الازمات الموجوده بين ايران وبقيه الدول
دكتور اشرت تقريبا لكل النقاط بما في ذلك
البحرين مع ان البحرين ليست مدرجه على اج
نده القمه العربيه حتى يتحدث عنها السيد
نوري المالكي لكنك لم تشر اطلاقا الى قضيه
الجزر الاماراتيه الثلاث مع انه موضوع
ساخن لحد الان هل يمكن ان يتم تجاهل هذا
الموضوع في هذه
الزياره انا اتصور قضيه الجزر قضيه محسومه
وليست لديها اي نوع من التدخل الجانب
الخليج الفارسي او الجانب العراقي يتدخل
في هذا لان هذا شان ايراني بح دكتور لكنها
ليست محسومه عربيا ولا دوليا على كل يعني
من الناحيه الدوليه ايضا ان الاتفاق
الموقع بين ايران وبين الامارات في ذلك
التاريخ مع العلم كان الاتفاق استعماري
وبريطاني ولكن يوجد في هذا الاتفاق بان
ايران تتمكن ان تكون لديها السيطره على
هذه الجزر بدون اي تفاوض مع الجانب الاخر
وهذا مصرح في هذا
المعاهده التي وقعت في سنه
1971 وليس امرا جيد جديدا اتصور بين ايران
والعراق وبين ايران والدول العربيه الدول
العربيه مع الاسف تؤكد م مرات عديده في
هذا المجال لقضيه الجزر ويعلمون ان الجانب
الايراني لديه رد واحد وان هذه القضيه
ايرانيه بحته ولا لا بد عدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للجانب الايراني نعم اذا
اذا واضح هناك تداخل في القضايا ال
الثنائيه والاقليميه فيما يتعلق بزياره
السيد المالكي الى طهران بعد الفاصل نتطرق
الى النتائج المتوقعه من هذه الزياره نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مازلتم
معنا في هذه الحلقه والتي نتناول فيها
زياره رئيس الوزراء نوري المالكي رئيس
الوزراء العراقي الى طهران دكتور عبد
الخالق عبد الله اذا تابعنا ما قاله
الدكتور حسن علي فيما يتعلق بقضيه الجزر
محسومه الامل الذي عربت عنه قبل قليل فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه طرح هذه القضيه يبدو ليس
في
محله اولا قضيه الجزر غير محسومه هذه جزر
اماراتيه والامارات ترى ان هذه الجزر حقها
ولا يمكن القبول بوضع اليد
وب بالاحتلال وبفرض امر الواقع على
الامارات وتاتي زياره احمدي نجاد لتؤكد
مره ثانيه كيف ان ايران تتعامل مع
الامارات باستعلاء هناك الان اجتماع قادم
لمجلس الوزراء العرب وسيكون هذا البند بند
جزر الامارات المحتله وزياره احمدي نجاد
البند الاول في الاجتماع القادم وعلى
العراق الذي سيتولى اداره هذا هذه الدوره
ان ان ان ان ان ان ان يكون واضحا في
الاجماع العربي
لمسانده الامارات في هذه القضيه واعتقد ان
من واجب المالكي الان ان يثير هذه القضيه
في طهران لان هذه الزياره تسببت في توتر
مزيد من التوتر في المنطقه وربما كان
بامكانه حيث انه صديق حميم لطهران ويران
ربما كان بامكانه ان يتدخل شخصيا ويضع ثقل
العراق ايضا وصداقه العراق مع ايران لحسم
هذا الموضوع عن حق وحقيقه عبر حل هذا
النزاع وليس عبر الابقاء على على الاحتلال
فالقضيب المالكيه الان حيث ان العراق
يتولى رئاسه الدوره الحاليه اثاره هذه
القضيه في زيارته الراهنه لطهران ولكني
اعتقد يعني هذا فيما يتعلق بالجزر ولكن
هناك قضيه ايضا مهمه موضوع سوريا سيد واثق
الهاشمي هل يمكن ان يكون حظ بغداد في
طهران فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف افضل من
الدوره
السابقه نعم قد يكون وضع بغداد صعب جدا
لوجود ثلاثه ملفات او ثلاثه زوايا مش
كبيره جدا اثرت على قوه العراق التفاوضيه
الا الاول وفيما يخص السيد المالكي تحديدا
وجود مشاكل داخليه كبيره بين الكتل
السياسيه وعدم اتفاقها على سياسه خارجيه
واحده في الكثير من القضايا المعروضه سواء
قضيه سوريا وتركيا وايران او حتى الجزر
العربيه الثلاثه القضيه الاخرى هناك تعويل
عربي على دور العراق كلاعب مهم وعائد بقو
هو الى حض او محيطه العربي ويترا اس
الجامعه العربيه لهذه الدوره في ان يستخدم
نفوذه وعلاقاته الجيده مع ايران كعضو او
كطرف مقبول من الطرفين لارساء كثير من
الخلافات الموجوده وتخفيفها اولها قضيه
الجزر العربيه الثلاثه والثاني القضيه
السوريه الضغط الثالث هو الضغط الايراني
نعم العلاقات العراقيه الايرانيه جيده
ايران اعطت الضوء الاخضر للسيد المالكي ان
يتولى الحكومه الثانيه بعد الانتخابات
الاخيره لكن وقد يجابه برد فعل ايراني
فيما يخص الجزر العربيه الثلاثه ورفض
ايراني في هذا الموضوع لكن قد يبدو الحظ
اوفر اذا كانت في القضيه السوريه على
اعتبارات كثيره ان الضغط على ايران اصبح
دولي في هذه القضيه وهناك تهديد لايران
بضربه محتمله قد يلجا السيد المالكي الى
خيارات مع الجانب الايراني في الوصول الى
حلول مشتركه ومقبوله لان العراق اكد انه
لن يخرج عن الاجماع العربي في هذا الموضوع
نعم اذا سلمنا بان السيد المالكي هو حليف
قوي لطهران دكتور حسن علي ما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه طهران من نتائج عمليه يعود بها
السيد المالكي ان على الصعيد الداخلي او
العربيط العراقيه كانت ناجحه في هذا
المجال وتتمكن ان تلعب دورا جيدا في تحسين
العلاقات بين ايران وبقيه الدول وخاصه دول
الخليج الفارسي التي شهدت بعض من التوتر
في المج الالات المختلفه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه واما بالنسبه للجزر اتفاقيه
1971 تؤكد بان الجانب الايراني هو مالك
لهذه الجزر وان العلم الايراني يرفع في
القسم الشمالي من جزيره ابو موسى ويرفع
العلم الاماراتي في القسم الجنوبي من
الجزيره وزياره السيد احمدي نجات الى هذه
الجزيره هو يعني الجانب الايراني و يكون
اي تدخل بالنسبه للجانب الاماراتي وبين
الايران والامارات علاقات وطيده وجيده
وحسنه ولا اتصور ايران اليوم تفكر بوء
العلاقات بين ايران وبين دوله الامارات
قضيه قضيه هذه الجزر قضيه هذه الجزر سيد
علي تعود الى 40 عاما ماذا عن ماذا عن
سوريا باختصار هل يمكن ان ان نسمع جديد من
طهران طبعا الملف السوري لديه دور كبير
الجانب العراقي في تحسين الظروف و التفاوض
مع الجانب الايراني لان الجانب الايراني
لديه علاقات قويه ومتينه مع الجانب السوري
ويتمكن الجانب الايراني ان يسهل التفاوض
بين المعارضه وبين الحكومه السوريه وتنفيذ
اتفاق كوفي عنان في المجالات المختلفه
خاصه في مجال تحسين الظروف للمواطنين
السوريين الذين يعانون بعض المشاكل بسبب
الارهاب التي يشاهدونها في بلدهم وايران
تتمكن ان تلعب دورا جيدا في في تنفيذ خطه
كوفي عنان كما كانت زياره كوفي عنان
ولقاءات كوفي عنان في ايران في هذا الاطار
واتصور سوف يكون الدور العربي يمثله
الجانب العراقي ويمثله دوله الرئيس نور
المالكي في هذا المجال شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور حسن علي الدبلوماسي الايراني
السابق واستاذ القانون الدولي كنت معنا من
طهران شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من بغداد واثق
الهاشمي رئيس المجموعه العراقيه للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من دبي
الدكتور عبد الخالق عبد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الامارات
بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
غدا باذن الله نلتقي في قراءه جديده فيما
وراء خبر جديد استودعكم
الله